Partir d'ici. ça tourne là? ok vas y!!
Ok l'heure est grave je suis saoulé
car pour la troisième fois en moins de six mois ils sont en train de péter complètement la rue
donc c'est marteaux piqueurs et compagnie
donc je me retrouve à tourner dans la réserve parce que sinon vous n'allez rien entendre!
Salut, dimanche dernier dans une vidéo de mcfly et carlito, Big Flo a deviné le prénom de quelqu'un sans aucun indice
"AUCUN INDICE !!!!"
mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est que à la fin il a dit ça:
"Les amis c'est très simple il va y avoir un inconnu qui va rentrer dans cette pièce
Vous ne le connaissez pas et on va devoir deviner son prénom. "  "Moi je le sens
Valentin."
"Je dois répondre maintenant ?" "Tu dois dire oui ou non"
"Quoi ?" "Tu te souviens de ton pote d'enfance, Valentin, je trouvais qu'il lui ressemble un peu et j'ai dit Valentin". "Regardez le il est en catatonie"
Cette réflexion est plus qu'intéressante et très pertinente. C'est un petit peu passé inaperçu mais le fait que big flo
s'inspire des prénoms des personnes qu'il a rencontrées dans sa vie ont augmenté
ses chances de trouver le bon prénom. Depuis 2017 ça porte un nom il y a eu des études dessus ça s'appelle l'effet Dorian Gray
on va en parler aujourd'hui dans la vidéo et vous allez pouvoir tester l'effet sur vous c'est parti! Loïc générique
*** c'est le générique de la vidéo de fabien olicard sur l'effet de Dorian Grayyyy****
Loïc tu va pas refaire ça!  Fais un vrai générique !  Ok
Ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui c'est complètement dingue ça peut paraître complètement
irrationnel
alors que c'est de la science durant cette vidéo je vais vous faire voir des images avec un sondage et des propositions de prénoms et
vous allez devoir essayer de deviner le prénom des personnes que vous allez voir à l'image tout a commencé avec une étude franco
israélienne publié le 27 février 2017 dans le journal suivant journal of personality and social psychologie
j'espère loïc que tu as trouvé l'image l'idée de base est très simple un prénom
déteindrait sur le visage de la personne qui le porte
d'où le nom de cet effet Dorian Gray en référence
au roman d'oscar wilde ou le jeune homme possède un tableau qui prend très cher à sa place à chaque fois qu'il fait la fête
c'est un résumé très simple
"Je veux dire qu'ils ont pas du tout fini les travaux" " d'accord
et
aussi pour te dire qu'on entend très bien les bureaux d'à côté quand on est
dans cet endroit" "c'est vrai" "oui" "enfin je pense qu'elles soient optimales alors... écoute c'est parfait voilà du coup bah
j'y vais." "Ah t'as une tête de loïc toi"  "c'est vrai? Ah bah tu vois ca tombe bien parce que je m'appelle Loic"
"Du coup tu vas monter les vidéos qu'on peut pas tourner ?" 'c'est ça!" "ok super ça c'est parfait allez merci"
donc notre visage serait tellement marqué par notre prénom qu'on serait capable de deviner le prénom de quelqu'un juste en regardant son visage
avec quelques conditions évidemment. En partant de l'hypothèse que nos caractéristiques physiques pouvait
épouser les stéréotypes de nos prénoms des chercheurs israéliens ont mis au point un test où ils ont montré des photos de 20 personnes dont
dix hommes et dix femmes qui avaient un visage neutre et où chaque photo avait une proposition de quatre prénoms différents
et parmi les quatre se trouvait le bon
la même expérience a été ensuite refait en france mais ce coup ci avec des visages et des prénoms rattachés à la culture française
et au final ce sont huit études qui ont été réalisées sur ce principe en france et en israël et les résultats ont été
identiques les huit fois il y a eu 35 à 40 % de bonnes réponses sur le choix des quatre prénoms avec sur certaines photos
des réussites allant jusqu'à 80%
80% 80% je ne sais pas si vous voyez à quel point quand même c'est énorme c'est juste ouf c'est à dire que le hasard
aurait voulu qu'on avoisine toujours les 25% de bonnes réponses là c'est pas hasardeux c'est 35 à 40 % avec des pics jusqu'à
80% j'insiste beaucoup parce que je trouve ça
ouffissimes. Mais ce qui est intéressant de la phrase qu'a dit big flo il faut avoir soi-même
1 stéréotype
du prénom qu'on recherche c'est à dire avoir rencontré au moins une personne voire plusieurs dans sa vie qui ont ce prénom la y avoir créé inconsciemment un
stéréotype de cette personne-là lire ce prénom en gros je vais vous expliquer pourquoi après cette étude prouve que quand
tu te dis tiens cette personne me fait penser à telle autre personne
alors il ya de fortes chances qu'ils aient le même prénom
alors évidemment tout n'est pas si simple dans le cas des prénoms rares par exemple même si les résultats sont au dessus du hasard
ils sont quand même moins bluffant
c'est également le cas des prénoms trop fréquent quand un prénom est trop fréquents et qu'on a rencontré trop de personnes qui portaient ce prénom
là alors ça bouzzille notre stéréotypes c"est même pas que ça le bouzille c'est
qu'il n'y a plus de
stéréotypes de base qu'on pourrait avoir lié à ce prénom parce qu'on a rencontré trop de personnalités différentes liées aux prénoms et bien sûr ça
ne fonctionne que si on appartient à la même culture de la personne présente sur la photo qu'on est de la même génération
de la même ethnie et potentiellement de la même catégorie
sociale c'est l'effet tribus qui s'applique où on reconnaît les personnes membres de notre propre tribu c'est quand même très étrange de se dire que
nous qui prenons le caractère unique de chaque personne on puisse se fier à quelque chose d'aussi contre-intuitif
intellectuellement parlant je parle qu un stéréotype
on va enchaîner avec le test que vous allez pourvoir faire là vous maintenant avec quatre photos différentes j'en profite aussi pour remercier Manon Brill
c'est elle qui l'année dernière en 2017 m'avait fait parvenir cette étude là et m'a fait découvrir ça merci beaucoup
lien dans la description elle est géniale. Je vous met également en descriptions quelques liens pour ceux qui veulent aller un petit peu plus loin mais
également un lien vers le site de
slate.fr
ils ont fait un article en février dernier sur ce sujet qui est très bien fait très intéressant et surtout ils sont amusés à remettre
des photos neutre dessus avec des prénoms différents et c'est celle ci qu'on va utiliser donc je les utilise là mais vous en
contrepartie allez tchéquez leurs articles voilà échange de bons procédés
vous pourrez aussi voir les résultats que ça a donné chez eux où il ya quand même
65 mille personnes qui ont répondu le premier visage apparaît à l'écran alors c'est un visage neutre d'après vous c'est un visage de quoi de
Sébastien de Thomas de Maxime ou de Vincent il a une tête de quel prénom comme ça quand vous voyez son visage vous vous dites
Ah il a une tête à s'appeler... Voilà faites confiance à votre intuition stéréotype est ce qu on appelle souvent l'intuition c'est juste
l'inconscient qu'à stocker des infos et qui vous les donne comme ça je vous laisse quelques
secondes assez courte pour réfléchir et vous avez au dessus de moi un sondage où vous pouvez mettre votre réponse
Pendant ce temps là je je me balade dans ce grand nouveau décor que vraiment je suis très très heureux d'avoir grâce aux travaux
Deuxième tête voici un nouveau visage cette jeune femme elle s'appelle Emilie
Elodie Aurélie ou Amélie,  vous avez les quatre propositions qui sont écrites autour de moi
réfléchissez, elle a une tête de
C'est tout,  je dis rien
non si je dis
quelque chose ça change tout
vous avez toujours le sondage au dessus de moi pour répondre allez y et on passe à la troisième photo
troisième photo elle apparaît maintenant est ce que cette jeune femme s'appelle Audrey Amélie Aurélie ou Aurore
réfléchissez mais pas trop longtemps aller piocher encore une fois dans Ah oui elle a une bonne tête de
quelque chose est voté au dessus je vais encore passer quelques secondes parce que sinon les votes
ne peuvent pas réapparaître il faut je crois au moins cinq ou six secondes
à chaque fois entre chaque vote quatrième et dernier essai donc 4e photos maintenant est ce que c'est un Cédric un Nicolas
Arnaud ou un Sébastien c'est votre dernier choix c'est la dernière fois que je chante comme ça
alors
cédric nicolas
arnaud
sébastien
et puis une autre question c'est pourquoi ils sont pas bien aligner les noms loïc
quoi
vous avez choisi vous votez au dessus on passe à la suite je vous donne les résultats dans quelques minutes à peine je veux juste
revenir sur ce qui va nous pousser à réfléchir un peu plus loin
l'interprétation des résultats de ces études qui ont été menées par hec paris l'université de jérusalem le idc et
l'université de colombie les ont amenés à l'hypothèse suivante le prénom que l'on reçoit est déjà plein de stéréotypes
inconscient pour l'entourage de la personne cet entourage va interagir avec l'enfant comme s'il avait déjà les
personnalités liées aux stéréotypes
deux personnalités évidemment qu'ils ont face à ce prénom voyez ce que je veux dire et en conséquence indirecte notre prénom peut changer notre propre
perception de nous-mêmes et influencer l'apparence de notre visage
la manière qu'on a de s'habiller de se préparer de se maquiller pour les filles
d'avoir une barbe comme ci ou comme ça pour les garçons est
évidemment quelque chose d'encore plus visible c'est la coupe de cheveux qu'on choisit d'avoir
pour ceux qui prennent le temps de se coiffer à ce jour et ça c'est fabuleux on n'a pas encore de données qui nous permettent
de comprendre pourquoi ça donne ses résultats art pour ça qu'on est juste sur des hypothèses de cause et tout ça paraît complètement
irrationnel alors que c'est complètement factuel mais une chose est sûre c'est que au delà du genre de notre ethnie et de notre catégorie sociale
le prénom c'est le premier marqueur social qu'on a vis-à-vis des autres
mais ce ne serait pas un marqueur social et dans le fond je trouve ça fabuleux parce que je fais des spectacles depuis presque dix
ans et je rencontre énormément de monde sur scène et
régulièrement
je ne suis pas
étonné que la personne est le prénom qu'elle l'a quand je lui demande pectacle que vous continuez à retrouver en tournée ici
lalalalalalalalala et des fois c'est complet c'est pour ça que vous réservez liens dans la description toi même tu sais voici maintenant le résultat des
quatre prénoms que vous avez vu j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
prenez une seconde pour la liké  si c'est le cas ce premier visage vous aviez le choix entre
sébastien thomas maxime où vincent et c'est un
vincent pour information quand moi j'ai fait le test j'avais pensé que c'était un maxime j'avais eu faux à celui ci
deuxième photo vous aviez le choix entre emilie Elodie (et l'audi -->lol google))aurélie et amélie et cette personne s'appelle
elodie est effectivement moi j'avais bien mis elodie aussi et ça m'avait fait bugger de ouf
troisième photo vous aviez le choix entre audrey amélie aurélie ou aurore et là elle s'appelle aurore et là aussi
j'avais trouvé le prénom est là aussi j'ai fais mais wath? et enfin la dernière photo cédric nicolas arnaud ou sébastien
personnellement j'avais hésité entre sébastien et arnaud j'avais mis arnaud et c'est arnaud
c'est le générique de la fin
t'es relou Loïc
bah non mais c'est parce que c'est pour annoncer que c'est la fin de la vidéo
il reste juste quelques secondes les gens ne vont pas rester, fais pas ça
mais si mais parce que comme ça moi je fais la chanson comme ça en plus à la fin je mets un truc de ouf
allez d'accord
cool
vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant ici et comme ça vous ne raterez pas les une à deux vidéos par semaine qui sortent en général
le mercredi matin et le samedi matin ici vous avez une vidéo que youtube vous recommande de regarder parce qu'ils connaissent votre
algorithmes c'est pas un stéréotype ils savent tout de vous ici c'est la dernière vidéo qui est sortie qui était très très cool
à très bientôt ciao